today the inflation numbers came out we
hit a 31-year high this is absolutely
historic and it is frankly sad breaking
us inflation was up 6.2
in october from a year ago the
year-over-year change of consumer prices
according to the cpi index is
6.2 percent the official numbers it's
the highest inflation in 31 years
inflation was up 0.9
in october alone a much higher increase
than 0.4 percent in september and 0.3
in august prices are rising for food
energy shelter used cars and new cars
absolutely bonkers what we are watching
right now we continue to see not only
high inflation not only persistently
high inflation but we are seeing
accelerating inflation it is getting
worse it is not getting better charlie
low had an absolute day this morning on
twitter i never just sit here and say
you know what this person just nailed it
i'm going to show you a bunch of tweets
he had this was probably one of the
greatest displays of inflation tweeting
that i have seen in a long time first up
one this is the current situation stocks
all-time highs home prices all-time
highs bitcoin all-time highs wages
all-time highs job openings all-time
highs inflation highest level in over 30
years guess what the fed in the
government wants to do ah we should hold
interest rates at zero and borrow and
spend trillions more absolute insanity
this is the definition of clown world
then charlie goes on and he shows the
price increases year over year of
various different goods gasoline is up
50
50
that is literally what happens in
developing nations this is the united
states of america supposed to be the
number one country in the world supposed
to be the leader the economic prosperity
the lighthouse on the hill and gasoline
is up 50
year-over-year gas utilities up 28
you guys better warm your wallets up
because your heat bill this year is
going to be bonkers use cars up 26
meat fish eggs up almost 12 new cars 9.8
electricity 6.5 overall cpi 6.2 percent
food whether you eat at home or you eat
at a restaurant it doesn't matter you
can't hide from the inflation it's over
five percent food prices whether you eat
at home or you eat out or over five
percent according to the official
numbers transportation four and a half
apparel 4.3 and shelter
3.5 if you believe that shelters only up
3.5 i got a lot of nonsense to sell you
because that is frankly not true
so whether we believe the official
numbers or not let's just look at the
official numbers absolutely insane to
see gasoline at 50
5-0 now if you go back here is the story
around inflation charlie all over this
janet yellen specifically said february
nothing to worry about in march small
and manageable in may it is only
temporary in june could reach three
percent but it is just transitory and
then in early october it's higher for
the next several months and in late
october trillions more in spending with
lower prices so when we go ahead and we
look at this what we see is that janet
yellen and others it's not just her
economists politicians and academics
just over and over and over again
gaslighting all of the american citizens
what we saw was that they were saying
that there was nothing to worry about to
begin with then they said oh there might
be a little bit of inflation but don't
worry then it was oh there might be high
levels of inflation but it may be
transitory and now we have 6.2 percent
inflation in this country in the
official numbers and the unofficial
number is likely over 10
if you use the 1980 measure for
inflation it is likely that we are
seeing somewhere between 13 to 15
inflation in the united states it is
insane so how does this stack up against
the rest of the world maybe it's just
relative everyone's inflation has gone
up and it's not that big of a deal well
that's not true we can go ahead here and
we can look at the global inflation
rates and we look at the global
inflation rates we can see in countries
like japan saudi arabia switzerland
they've always had pretty low levels of
inflation not a huge deal but if we
start to look at the u.s right they're
highlighted in blue it's at 6.2 percent
who is around us
mexico poland russia
are those the people that we normally
compare ourselves to when it comes to
economic prosperity and inflation well
what about brazil or what about
argentina venezuela etc this is insane
6.2
inflation is the highest that this has
been in 31 years for those of you
sitting at home trying to think
31 years that is 1990. i was born in
1988.
this is the highest level of inflation
that we have seen in my lifetime
literally the highest level of inflation
in my lifetime my two brothers the
highest level of inflation they've ever
seen in their lifetime
so no matter how you cut it whether you
want to describe there's high level
inflation you wanna say it's the highest
in 31 years you wanna say it's the
highest level in literally anyone below
the age of 35 the highest level of
inflation in their lifetime absolutely
nuts now when we look at the commodity
prices it's not just consumables that
are going up commodities are going up as
well we have crude and heating oil and
gasoline and brent crude all up over 100
percent year over year
100
in a year
coffee is up 88
coffee
you outperform the s p 500 if you bought
coffee and just held on to it
natural gas again your heating bill this
winter is going to be bonkers up 74
cotton copper aluminum corn sugar wheat
all up over 30
and of course lumber soybean silver all
positive as well but you know it's down
gold the classic inflation hedge has
failed literally gold has lost value
against the dollar now if we go ahead
and we look tommy ball game coming in
hot this morning he said that he was
looking at the inflation numbers and he
did a little research this is original
research by tommy ball game my uh my
favorite spy uh contributor and so
average gas price in october 2020 2.25
cents today it's 3.38 cents plus 67
67
then average price of dozen eggs up 28
the average sale price of a house sold
in the united states is up 14
absolutely bonkers
now senator manchin coming out and just
saying what everyone is realizing
clearly stating the threat posed by
record inflation to the american people
is not transitory and is instead getting
worse
they said it was going to be transitory
they said it over and over and over
again they were wrong it is now we have
experienced multiple months of over five
percent inflation and now we have over
six percent inflation it is getting
worse it is not getting better so every
single economist every single academic
every single politician every single
person that kept telling you it was
transitory they're wrong the test is
over the game is over no matter what
happens moving forward they were wrong
it is not transitory now of course i've
got to get in on the memes inflation
will be transitory sure clown world type
stuff
of course
zero hedge they got to get their shot in
as well they said the fed's
hyperinflation mandate is going great
obviously they're joking around here but
i don't know how much of a joke it
really is when people are experiencing
and the official number is over six
percent inflation and the real numbers
likely closer to 15
and so inflation is so bad it is
literally so bad that it is now trending
on twitter we live in a country where
the inflation and the monetary policy
and fiscal policy decisions have been so
undisciplined and so poor that it drove
such high inflation that it literally
trends on twitter
which tells you everything you need to
know people are paying attention people
are starting to understand this and so
what i've been saying for years now
is that there is one asset in the world
it is an asymmetric asset it's a
non-correlated asset and it is the
single best inflation hedge asset in the
entire world
on top of that not only did i say it but
plenty of others did as well if you go
back to last year paul tudor jones said
i think that i'm going to need inflation
hedge assets i want to be with the
fastest horse be with bitcoin and so
when that cpi print came out at 6.2
percent guess what bitcoin did it took
off like a rocket ship and hit 69 000
which is a brand new all-time high for
the digital currency this is what ends
up happening when you continue to have
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
you drive all
assets up whether they are consumable
goods things like food or used cars or
other types of assets like that
or we are talking about investment
assets where you see the stock market
you see every commodity you see bitcoin
and you see real estate all exploding in
price the currency is being devalued at
a historic rate it has not devalued at
this rate for 30 years
30 years we have not seen this
and so anyone who's telling you don't
worry about it maybe we should stop
worrying what they say and we should
actually start paying attention and
asking ourselves what can i do to
protect myself because i don't see any
relief on the horizon